we know what kids need and even if it's
only 90 right getting 90 right at the
moment was more important than 100 100 a
year a year later so by the way for
everyone who's listening
72 right yeah I mean everyone's trying
to be 100 right where 72 gets you into
the Hall of Fame of business and
communication hey everybody Welcome to
the garyvee audio experience uh in my
continuation of finding interesting
people to talk to and do original
content I'm excited about this one I'm
extremely excited about it because this
was probably the most conversation
pre-filming because I like to keep it
very improv but Steve Hit me hard with
his Jets fandom and so that excites me
uh and then obviously for everybody
listening at home you know the journey
I'm on with the be friends intellectual
property and early on I thought I was
going more Pokemon and Disney when I
would talk to it about my friends but
with the ambition I have of putting
positivity into the world with the
traits I and just by meeting people
along the way that worked with Jim
Henson and things of that nature I
didn't realize how much Sesame Street
DNA is in V friends and so it is a
stunningly big honor of mine Temps Steve
on the show Steve why don't you tell
everybody who you are and what you do
and then we'll rock and roll all right
well thank you for having me
um I am speaking I'm one of the CEO of
Sesame Workshop and for those who don't
know your Sesame Workshop best known for
making Sesame Street but we were a
global
um not-for-profit media education
organization with a mission of helping
kids grow stronger smarter and Kinder
and I like to the things that you know
three four things about the workshop we
focus in early childhood because you
know that's where you think you can have
the greatest long-term impact into this
business oriented the greatest return on
investment you know we focus on the
cognitive skills but really the whole
child because we're really about getting
the kid ready for life and it's much
more about you know numbers and writing
it's about social emotional it's about
uh you know positive identity it's about
you know emotional well-being and that
you know for two reasons we focus on
media you know because kids consume a
lot of it and technology and so it's
never about if they're learning it's
about what they're learning so let's
harness that with something that can
prepare them for life but also from the
day one when Joan and Lloyd the founders
started it was it was basically it was
incredibly scalp so if you want to reach
kids at scale and engaging away and do
it and make a difference you know that's
who we are I love it
what um before we go into the macro what
um
because I have a lot of questions about
just the great work you've been doing
during covid
the Ever Changing landscape of
distribution of information when I think
about Sesame from my standpoint it's one
of the I was born in Belarus and it was
Sesame Street was one of the ways I
learned English and I you know I also we
were poor so we had no cable so there
wasn't a lot of channels and Sesame
Street was always there
um you know when I think about Sesame in
the 70s and 80s from a consumption reach
standpoint that was such a big Advantage
you know obviously now the fragmentation
of media and streaming and CTB and so
curious in your perspective on that I'm
I'm pumped that for a lot of people this
might be the first time they've realized
there's so much more to the organization
than just that content but before we go
into all of that I always like to talk
to the person you know when you were a
little guy did you expect to be the CEO
obsessive like give me a little conflict
let's do three or four minutes on you
how you grew up what kind of dude you
were uh and your career and then we'll
bounce back to the macro yeah so I uh I
I grew up in New York I always say did I
expect to be
um become a CSS feed No but in
retrospect I probably should have I was
born in 69 and sesame was founded in 69
and as Gary and I were talking it's also
the last time the Jets won January 12th
one of the best days in in history I was
negative six you know as I grew up with
the memories of Big Bird sort of walking
out on stage and sort of comfort and
warmth and and now in retrospect the
knowledge that I actually got from it
but I was um you know I was in some ways
your normal sort of black kid I love
sports I loved being a kid you know I
think about your book I had the thing
it's economically unsound to grow up
because I you know it embrace the
kingdom the journey wasn't straight I
did a lot of things you know my most
recent you know it's been a long time at
Vicon is building you know the biggest
brands on a kind of a macro level like
MTV Nickelodeon but then on a micro
level like SpongeBob you know and Dora
and sort of Etc and that's probably the
journey that took you there I saw the
power of media I saw how I can engage I
saw how Brands cut across platforms uh
at very stages of the disruption of the
digital transformation that you kind of
just got to and it was that like and I
got myself interested in more
educational working on some outside
companies and being on some boards and
I'm like wow if I could harness my
expertise in media and how that can
engage and move people and sort of
Target it at a sort of at a cause and a
mission because Sesame entertains but it
entertains a compor to educate and I can
say that expertise bring it to sort of a
smaller organization where I could have
even more impact both from what it's
doing but also in terms of the world I
was like well that's a nice little
career Arc and it wasn't the goal when I
started but it certainly became the
natural role as it went online good for
you what did you go in at Viacom as
I went in I was there 17 years I I was
your I'm one of your uh you know
business school guys Mackenzie McKenzie
I went to Stanford yep and I went into
what were you always were you always
good at school like that came natural to
you
it came I always liked school and it
came you know pretty natural and what I
liked I don't even know is the academic
part I just loved exploring ideas and I
was like a true major in intelligence
and you know just who was got obsessed
with the how the past shapes the future
and uh yeah I'm into that too actually
it shakes and constraints future and I I
just love ideas and and and the way
ideas can shape the world and shape the
mind so from that perspective uh I love
you know school not enough to go get a
PhD it was really like how do you do it
and make a difference in the real world
I'm not the phds don't make a difference
the real world but it wasn't the time
from the knowledge to go to I totally
understand what are you like when you're
having dinner actually let's go dinner
conversation here a little bit yeah you
know given that job you're meeting
people you know obviously kovid's been
weird but like probably starting now and
definitely before covid you know on
board you know fundraisers dinners kids
school like you know in life when when
you tell them you have this job you know
it's not like a normal mundane like oh
you're executive if you stayed at
McKinsey like oh cool like you like that
it you get real reactions yeah right you
probably I mean I would argue I'm sure
I'm gonna guess this pretty right
minimally seven out of eight or six out
of ten or seven eight out of ten people
immediately go into an immediate story
of how Sesame affected them or who they
liked right
yeah it is the you know you go in
people's jobs you have expectations I
think the one that I had not completely
anticipated is how much
the brand and the organization
around the world and I mean that around
the world but the story you told was one
I did not go in I was wide open which is
a number of people who go around learned
English from Sesame yeah you you you
know the number you go to Japan you go
to the Middle East you you already
you're here and the Immigrant children
who said yes that's what I learned both
parents and kids and adults or the
memories that they had how that that
either it touched them it taught them
the the um you know we have a board
member
um who's Hispanic and who saw Maria
growing up yeah and it's huge it's huge
and that sort of like um representation
that validation of like the
representation was extreme on and I grew
up in you know a lot of blue-collar
neighborhoods that had huge diversity
and
um I even remember like being affected
by that right like you know it was huge
uh to that point of people responding
that way I after they tell you like
Maria did this or when Oscar the Grouch
did that or I learned you know
um
when people go into like what's going on
with it now like you know if we're
having that combo because I think it's
important for people to hear this
because I have a lot of affinity for the
brand what is going on with it now like
what like you've got a lot of very
senior Executives and a lot of
entrepreneurs that are going to change
the world listening to this podcast I
think that's an important platform for
them to hear on what in a world where
they may want to join or business
develop with what is going on now yeah
so
um one amazing thing and and this is
probably a side of almost all a great
company is it a tribute to the founders
and that gets you to the now is Jonah
Lloyd are the founders who are still
alive today and like sometimes in
reality and sometimes in spirits for my
mentors they had their North Star
Concepts and a lot of them was what they
want to do and you know Focus an early
childhood focus on the whole child and
focus on leveraging media and Technology
to reach and engage
the what that means today is completely
different you know and you know when we
started it was like and but what it what
what drives us is not that like what are
the issues that matter most what are the
ones relevant to kids and how are we
going to reach them with the latest sort
of technology and and idiots and that is
when we started I mean it's hard for
most people on this podcast probably
weren't even born back then four Channel
television channels yeah linear no
on-demand that's right literally the
show was reached 70 of all kids it was
preschool on TV there were 100 something
episodes and it was Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday to do that today you
know you you know to be yes I'm linear
yes I'm streaming yeah um yes on YouTube
yes on WhatsApp yes on on I'm Jake
talking yes into schools yes with
community centers fragmentation it's the
it's the necessity and it's a huge
opportunity and what has made us keep
driving is probably three things is one
is making sure the content evolves into
engaging because you can't you know we
constantly change the show and iterating
you know and making sure it's
entertaining from that perspective
making sure we're addressing the most
relevant issues and and whether that's
certain types of representation or when
code would happen or after the terrible
tragedy of George Floyd really leaning
into self-identity and belonging to now
you're going to see it lean into uh you
know emotional health and well-being and
then making sure you're actually
reaching the audiences in the way and
it's not it's this that and the other
thing and the beautiful thing that's
transformed with us now is like we're
used to completely be one to men because
he had a TV he was a dumb box that just
and now it's one to many but now on when
we go digital we go into communities we
go into schools we can be one to few or
even one to one there's some amazing
stuff we're doing in the Middle East on
WhatsApp and really like targeting and
delivering the message at the moment
when you can to Syrian refugee children
and their families that need it most so
the key for us is what's your North Star
check it sometimes because it may evolve
but constantly evolved The Playbook to
adapt to the way consumers are playing
and take advantage of the technologies
that are at your hands are delivered and
that's what we have done and I would say
the last unique thing about us which is
our opportunity and challenges we're not
for profit we're an independent
organization we were a for-profit
someone would have bought us by now I
always say yeah because that's how
things go so are we flipped on the side
is we just make great Partnerships you
know we're as good as our partners and
whether that's Partners to reach the
audience whether it's hard to fund our
work or whether it's Partners to build
the brand and those are the three things
we need and
um you know allows us to say true or
north star get virtual scale and have
outsized impact for the size of Who We
Are I love that what um what was most
surprising
in the beginning of covid to now if I
said recap the day it all shut down to
right now
from a brand standpoint or an execution
standpoint anything stand out it could
be a good insight for people
yeah for it
for everybody it was a transformational
moment that changes in ways I don't
think any of us really completely know
yet right but as our organization it
transformed us
uh in the moment it was like oh my God
like everybody we went home but you know
we also then a week later did that I
remember watching uh
watching Jimmy Fallon or someone doing
their show from the from the bathtub and
I was like hey you know what we're a
kiss thing but we're not anime we were
animated but we're also live action get
those Muppets home get them some cameras
before they sell out on Amazon and you
know we're gonna meet this moment and
engage kids and I think that it scared
us because we're one that research
driven and thoughtful and pulling in and
we do this to make sure it's really
having the educational impact but here
we realize like wow kids need us now
families need us now and necessity was
the mother of invention we started to do
some you know short form putting on
YouTube and then we're like you know
what wow we can do this we called up our
friends then Manuel and Miranda we
called up and afterway we did a special
that went from completely remote that
went on air across seven channels across
water and PBS I remember you see NHK uh
you know TVs Tech sort of et cetera and
I think where it transformed us as an
organization question was that you know
we've been doing this for 50 years so
while we we know what kids need and even
if it's only 90 right getting 90 right
in the moment was more important than
100 100 a year a year later so by the
way for everyone who's listening
72 right
I mean everyone's trying to be 100
72 gets
education
and that is a that gave us and then
again we started doing these CNN Town
Halls where we greenlighted on a Monday
and be on air on a Saturday addressing
heavier issues whether the fears and
motion to covert or then we did this
coming together special or
um following George Floyd's death to
helping kids and families cope
we um you know it was gave us confidence
to trust you know what's funny when you
talk about it what the brand did was in
my opinion was get out of its its bubble
and become more oxygen instead of being
like this like a thing it became an
overlaying oxygen in in other
distribution formats and topics yeah
but playing into the DNA which is that
we know the kids and families and if you
get the right Partners you can yeah to
your to your point it's a distribution
an awareness statement not an essence of
who you are statement as a matter of
fact the essence of who you are gave you
the permission for those people to want
and need you to do that yeah and I think
it gave us the validation as we kind of
that in times of Crisis people turn to
Brands they trust and it's up to you as
a brand to meet that moment or not and I
believe we met that moment and that's in
some ways
I'm gonna go very nerdy and very selfish
I apologize podcast latest nurse
um
how does the organization if it does at
all think about the ebb and flow of the
characters who are most popular of the
moment
right so I I think a lot about Elmo yeah
it's popularity today yeah I see it
right versus big birds popularity in
1975 versus Oscar and Grover I think
about the characters a lot where I would
say that the face of the brand has
evolved over the last 50 years
is that a conversation do people that do
people have like feelings like Oscar
needs more shine
it show a couple things some of it are
generational I'm a big bird guy yeah you
know when I grow up there was no element
and so it is you know is like that
really hard interview question we
interviewed somebody he's like so who's
your favorite Muppet which I'm gonna I
can guess who yours is but you know my
you know who mine is and has nothing
it's the reverse of my personality Oscar
the Grouch do you know why
I was gonna say Oscar no you were not
yes I was I'm proud of you brother Oscar
is 100 my favorite character because he
was green and that and like green was
the foundation of my Jets fan like it's
all been green it was all about green
you know I also think he's sweet with a
fake exterior
you know we have a in our upcoming
season you know there are many ways we
stay relevant some ways is having you
know certain celebrities on and we had
[Music]
um
Fred Goldstein you know Roy Kansas who
you can imagine had a bond with Oscar
yeah there's he is Oscar nice characters
ring and he did the special word of the
letter of the day what letter do you
think it was
a
F
I like the way he runs like hey like you
know it's so funny when Roy Kent I
watched that I consumed more television
during covet than anything with Ted
lasso
I literally literally believe his entire
character is based on Oscar the Grouch
uh he that moment and there's a you know
him and scram going up to Oscars you'll
see it season 53 premiering you know
very soon but so the answer is it is a
bit of a generational thing and I don't
know that personality thing in different
Generations
um and we do uh and today is no
ambiguity if you look at the Q scores of
kids it is Elmo if you look at the Q
Sports adults it gets into like Cookie
Monster and Grover and you know where
you know what she was sitting here as
you were talking I'm sorry to interrupt
I also have to give a huge shout out to
Snuffaluffagus it was he he was stuffy
was so crazy like I was like he's so
like he was just bigger than life and so
like I know well that's other Beauties
like you have the core six seven eight
you know Burton Ernie obviously yeah
huge yep but then there are the you go
it's a world I don't know if I call it a
Marvel Universe but it's a world of
their Snuffy there's the you know
there's the characters that people all
have that special moment to I think what
we struggle with is that and again this
is where the multiple platforms do and
of course shows you know too many
characters over well our core audience
is kids for the show obviously when you
go beyond it onto tick-tocks poor show
we need to keep the focus because if you
have too many characters you don't get
the Affinity but the beautiful about all
the various platforms whether it's
YouTube whether it's tick tock whether
it's
um you know a Twitter where they all
have their own character accounts as you
can actually interact with who you you
know most sort of connect with and have
that connect um and have that sort of
bond and it's um so that's how we sort
of balance it but we definitely have the
debate and we hope to rely on research
because internally people I like this
character I like that character and you
try not to if you fragmented too much of
course from a kid's perspective but um
it works in many other areas with five
minutes to go in this great podcast and
I could do this for five hours with you
and I'd love to catch a drink sometime
because I between the Jets and character
development this is for you to the set I
mean
and I'm in they're like I'm locking that
in team are you hearing this I'm 100
um uh what what have we not touched on
that you want this audience to know or
some or something that you're thinking
about or what have we not touched on
um you know I think that some people
don't
um and I'll leave a final thought which
I sort of mean from the bottom of my
heart I think people
um don't know completely the depth and
breadth of the work that we're doing I
agree I agree you've got alluded to like
the U.S some things you know as we got
into sort of all the stages of covid yep
um to helping people you know families
talk about all the issues that came up
in the summer of 20 you know following
George Floyd and now we're taking on
self-identity and belonging it in a deep
way but there's a global work you know
you coming from where you didn't know we
were Global yeah we've been Global for
you know it started to punch Central
American show in 69 next year is going
to be the 50th Anniversary continuous of
the German version of sesame strassa but
now you know in a world that we try to
you know prioritize the most vulnerable
children as mission-driven um
not-for-profit and the issues that
matter most we are working in the Syrian
refugee region trying to bring early
childhood education with a great partner
on the ground IRC
um combining mass media with Direct
Services we are in Bangladesh with some
wonderful funding from Lego Foundation
you know work in crisis settings in
Latin America in Africa and now we are
deep working on how we can support
Afghanistan after last year and now in
Ukraine the the the the same sort of
Mantra early childhood education don't
forget about it they need food they need
shelter yeah but if you lose that
generation you've lost a generation and
in some parts of the world other forces
will fill them in yes and it has a
lifetime impact and I think that's
something that people just don't know
the depth and breadth of you know some
people used to call it monthly diplomacy
you know we just call it like servicing
all kids and and making sure that we're
having the greatest impact that we have
so that that's that the domestic work
and that we're much more than a TV show
you know we we assume there's a media
platform of technology that kids and
families are consuming and we are there
and that's where we want to continue
and what I leave is the Mantra I will
keep going this goes to you too Gary by
the way which is like we're as good as
our partners yeah so you know if someone
you know everyone should care about kids
because kids are the future so if
someone thinks that they can help us
deliver there from reaching the audience
from from our financial perspective or
elevating the brand because the Brand's
the top of the funnel you know that
that's the to your audience
um and and by the way and having some
fun too because
and without finding it we don't engage
in nothing
you can't teach I I agree I think the
fun and the stories and the characters
is is the reach and I think you know
you've spoke on it obviously you have a
good grasp on it the fragmentation of
attention is very different than when
this brand started and that leads to
enormous opportunity I actually think it
leads to deeper character development
opportunities because you can segment in
different ways so nonetheless this is
super enjoyable I look forward to thank
you for the invite I will 100 take you
up on it
all right awesome thank you my friend
let's find bad dolphins
[Music]